okay so now we're gonna talk about the
phenomenological existential /
phenomenological psychiatrists and their
theories from the 1950s and as I
mentioned to you before a lot of their
thinking was motivated by what had
happened in in World War two when I when
I lectured to you last I pointed out I
described Nietzsche and Dostoyevsky's
summation of the world situation and
really the world psychological situation
at the end of the 1800s and that was
that our new modes of thinking had
undermined our faith in our old modes of
thinking and that was a problem because
people need something for him to stand
on to orient themselves and to move
forward and so Nietzsche and Dostoevsky
basically both prophesied that the
consequence of that dissolution would be
increased probability of nihilism and
everything that went along with that and
Dostoevsky wrote about that actually
quite extensively in a book called notes
from underground which if any of you are
interested especially in clinical
psychology that's a book you should
really read because it's one of the most
brilliant psychological studies of a
psychologically disturbed man that's
ever been written it's very accurate and
there are sections in crime and
punishment that are like that - I think
they're unsurpassed in their
representation of sight of psychological
phenomena I don't I don't know how he
managed it I mean Dostoevsky was
epileptic I don't know if you know that
but he he was arrested by the czars men
in the late 1800s for being a student
radical and they threw him and then they
imprisonment in Moscow and then one day
they took him out in front of a firing
squad and shot him at 6:00 in the
morning but they only used blanks which
of course he didn't know about and that
scared him so badly he developed
epilepsy and then he had epileptic and
by the way and he had epilepsy for the
rest of his life but he had this strange
kind of epilepsy which is actually not
all that rare sometimes when people have
epilepsy they they experienced this
phenomena they call an aura which is an
altered state of consciousness before
epileptic seizure hits and they can be
very strange these auras so I read a
case study once about a guy who his aura
was that his hand was being possessed by
Devils from Hell and he could feel the
possession move up his arm and into his
shoulder and once it hit his head he to
have an epileptic seizure and so then
there was another case where where this
man his aura was that his exact double
had appeared behind him but if he turned
and if he turned to look then he'd have
an epileptic seizure but if he didn't
turn to look that he wouldn't so these
you know brain disorders are very
strange things because they're well the
system that is disordered is alive and
it's capable of any number of
extraordinarily peculiar misbehaviors
anyways Dostoyevsky's aura was a world
revealing aura and so what Dostoyevsky
would experience was that the meaning of
things got deeper and deeper and deeper
and deeper and deeper and then just as
he was on the verge of discovering the
secret to everything he'd have an
epileptic seizure but he said that the
quality of experience during the aura
was so high so overpowering and so deep
that he would have traded all of his
normal experience just to have had those
experiences and he had them repeatedly
and I really do believe that it was this
broadening of his of his vision and
concept by his epilepsy that transformed
him among other things I mean he went
through some pretty damn rough
experiences because he was in prison
with rapists and murderers for a long
time in Siberia even though he was kind
of an heiress to Craddock guy I mean he
had a he had a rough time of it and I I
imagine that that also broadened him
tremendously given that it didn't kill
him but I really do believe that the
epileptic in sight was key to his like
his unsurpassed genius and so and the
his aura and other people do experience
epileptic aura symptoms like that by the
way and some people are so enamored of
the aura that they won't take their anti
epilepsy medication because they don't
want to forego the experience that
precedes the aura or the actual actual
epileptic seizure
so Dostoyevsky's experiences the the aw
element of the aura is also relevant to
we're going to talk about today because
both binswanger and and boss were very
interested in how meaning revealed
itself in the world and they had to know
they had opposing explanations I
actually think they're parallel
explanations but the meaning that
Dostoyevsky experienced is is an
amplification of the normal manner in
which meaning reveals itself in the
world
so I mean and people experience that
sort of thing in in various altered
states of consciousness